es sind wirklich super mysteriöse
signale die fachleute schon im oktober
2018 oberhalb der antarktis aufgespürt
hatten bei dieser sogenannten anita
anomalie handelt es sich um
ungewöhnliche radiowellen die nach
ansicht mancher forschungsteams nur mit
bislang unbekannten elementarteilchen zu
erklären sind
eine neue analyse offenbart jetzt dass
sich diese rätselhafte signale wohl
nicht mit konventioneller physik
erklären lassen aber womit denn dann
klicks und science fiction gibt's
täglich spannendes seien sie das
abonniert den kanal und aktiviert die
glocken und dann verpasst ihr nichts los
geht's willkommen und herzlichen dank
auch für den spannenden themen vorschlag
aus unserer telegramm community von
alexander diese messergebnisse haben
physikerinnen und physiker weltweit
regelrecht elektrisiert im herz 2018
hatte der sogenannte anbieter mesz
ballon ein signal registriert das auf
höchst rätselhafte elementarteilchen
hinweis diese signale kamen dabei nicht
mal vom himmel den an die da eigentlich
absurd sondern vom boden an mieter steht
dabei für antarctic impulsiv champion
tanner und wurde von der nasa entwickelt
konkret handelt es sich um einen
detektor der an einem ballon in 40
kilometern höhe über der eiswüste des
südpols schwebt die nasa will mit diesem
gerät hinweise auf neutrinos mit extrem
hohen energien einfangen die in der
atmosphäre auf atome treffen und dann
mit ihnen interagieren also sie selbst
können gar nicht delektiert werden
sondern nur über atome mit denen sie
reagiert haben verrückt bei den
neutrinos handelt sich um wirklich sehr
seltsame elementarteilchen oft auch als
geister teilchen benannt der deutsche
physiker wolfgang pauli hatte sie
bereits 1930 vorhergesagt experimentell
wurden sie dann 1956 nachgewiesen diese
teilchen haben keine ladung und eine
sehr sehr kleine masse sie entstehen im
inneren der sonne und anderen sternen
und von ihnen aus gelangen
unvorstellbare mengen dieser geister
teilchen ins all das auch der
menschliche körper in jeder sekunde von
milliarden neutrinos durchdrungen wird
das ist kaum vorstellbar aber wahr
der plan sah also vor dass anita den
himmel absucht denn von dort kommen
genau die partikel die für astro- und
teilchenphysik rinnen und physiker
weltweit höchst spannend
doch die mysteriöse signale von atomen
die mit neutrinos reagiert hatten kamen
nicht von oben sondern von unten aus dem
eis der antarktis sie kam also aus der
erde und erreichten dabei die enorme
energie von 0,6 ex elektronenvolt extra
steht übrigens für trillionen
elektronenvolt also wirklich der
absolute wahnsinn
schon damals wurde gemutmaßt ob anita
damit die tür zu einer komplett neuen
physik aufgestoßen hat handelt es sich
etwa um die signatur einer neuen bislang
noch unentdeckten klasse von
elementarteilchen fest steht lediglich
dass sogenannte standardmodell der
teilchenphysik hat noch lücken und somit
luft nach oben
die wissenschafts community ist sich
sicher das ist noch sehr viel zu
entdecken gibt was bislang im
verborgenen blieb und so gab es bereits
damals einige theorien zu den seltsamen
messungen beispielsweise das innerhalb
der erdkugel eine andere dichte
verteilung von dunkler materie
vorherrscht als im weltall
diskutiert wurden eben auch neutrinos
die als auslöser in frage kommen könnten
die messdaten der verdächtigen teilchen
kaskade zeigten damals eindeutig dass
sie aus richtung der erdoberfläche
kommen
der clou dabei mit hilfe des winkels der
eintreffenden strahlung können fachleute
auf die bewegungsrichtungen der
ursprünglichen teilchen rückschließen
das heißt also dass sie die erde am
nordpol getroffen haben müssten um diese
dann komplett zu durchqueren
dann könnten sie möglicherweise in der
atmosphäre über dem südpol die lawine
losgetreten haben in frage kommen
aufgrund dieser erkenntnis entweder nur
sehr energiereichen neutrinos oder aber
komplett neue elementarteilchen die wir
noch nicht kennen
doch endgültig gewährt werden konnten
die rätselhafte signale bis heute nicht
jetzt hat eine neue analyse
stattgefunden doch auch sie bringt kein
licht ins dunkel so wie erhofft im
gegenteil die anita anomalie wird so nur
noch rätselhafter denn das
forschungsteam des clubs kann neutrinos
viel direkter nachweisen als anita seit
mehr als neun jahren suchen hier 300
vorstellungen forscher aus mehr als zehn
ländern nach zerfalls spuren von
neutrinos im ewigen eis sind
empfindliche detektoren installiert die
den sehr seltenen blitz einfangen
der entsteht wenn hochenergetische
neutrinos auf ein wassermolekül treffen
und das observatorium macht wird
ich gute arbeit sind schon zahlreiche
blitze entdeckt worden vor zwei jahren
2018 wurde der weg eines geisterhaften
teilchens aus einer fernen galaxie bis
zu unserem südpol nachverfolgt doch
derartige signale lassen sich zum
zeitpunkt der auszeichnung durch ein
mieter einfach nicht aufspüren
so schreibt es das icecube autorenteam
in seiner aktuellen studie die lektoren
auf der ganzen welt die die neutrinos
direkt nachweisen können haben zu diesem
zeitpunkt also kein einziges solches
kosmisches ereignis registriert und so
können die geister teilchen quasi als
verursacher der anita anomalie
ausgeschlossen werden dazu die
physikerin anastasia bahnhof von der
universität genf dieser prozess macht
ice cube zu einem bemerkenswerten
instrument um die anbieter beobachtung
zur verfolgung der ice cube für jedes
anormal ereignis das er niger entdeckt
viele viele weitere hätte erkennen
müssen was wir in diesen fällen nicht
getan haben doch was hat die mysteriösen
radiosignale sonst verursacht hat anita
vielleicht einen fehler gemacht
messfehler können nicht ausgeschlossen
werden erst recht nicht in der neutrino
forschung vor einigen jahren war
beispielsweise eine studie
veröffentlicht worden dass neutrinos
schneller als licht sein doch das
stellte sich später als messfehler
heraus aber auch andere dinge sind
vorstellbar und die wissenschafts
community ist on fire denkbar sind auch
banale erklärung so was wie radiowellen
die auf plötzlichen schwankungen im
erdmagnetfeld repräsentieren doch das
rätselraten geht weiter denn auch eine
neue physik jenseits des standardmodells
ist weiterhin nicht ausgeschlossen so
auch die meinung des physikers alexander
petto demnach könnte sich auch um
bislang unbekannte teilchen handeln die
den hoch energetischen neutrinos ähneln
und ähnlich wie diese wirken aber
möglicherweise anders erzeugt werden die
theorie der supersymmetrie sagt solche
teilchen ja voraus im laufe diesen
jahres 2020 jedenfalls könnten wir der
lösung jedenfalls ein stückchen näher
kommen denn dann werden neue messdaten
von anita erwartet es ist wirklich
wirklich der absolute mal was wir so
alles herausfinden um was der kosmos
noch so alles für überraschungen
bereithält das geheimnis der
akkretionsscheibe junge sterne und weiße
zwerge anklicken anschauen und egis
kostenlos abonnieren cooler neuer kanal
bei unserem kleinen wissenschafts
netzwerkes 1054 bis dann
bleibt dran